Republicans taking the battle for border
security to Capitol Hill lawmakers
sparring for hours during the hash
Judiciary committee's first hearing on
the border crisis we have set records
for migrants coming into the country and
frankly
I think it's intentional communities
have been neglected and banned to rely
on our own local and state resources to
address border that is in a crisis mode
Kamala Harris was appointed the borders
are have you had a lot of interaction
with her no
but Democrats fired back
the first hearing will showcase the
racist Tendencies of the extreme
Republican wing of the party many
republicans in Congress seem a tent on
demonizing migrant families portraying
them as Fentanyl traffickers and violent
criminals it's not Biden's border crisis
this has been a crisis for over half a
century
here to react is Texas Congressman
nathal Nathan Nathaniel Moran a member
of the House Judiciary Committee
Congressman thanks for being with us
this morning last time I checked the U.S
welcomes people and migrants as long as
it's done safely and legally but I do
want your reaction to the Democrats
calling This Racist and a distraction by
the GOP
well happy groundhog day and yesterday
was very informative because what we saw
effectively was that the Democrats saw
their Shadow and signaled to the United
States to the American people that
they're going to see continue to open
border policies over the next two years
without regards to our rule of law and
clearly you know we had folks on the on
the panel that were giving us a
first-hand testimony about what was
going on more than half of our Border
Protection agents are Hispanic in nature
this is not a racist issue this is a
secured National Defense issue this is
an issue we have to fix quickly yeah
Congressman Moran I think when you hear
the Democrats go to their standard oh
everything's racist line of defense you
know that their position is untenable so
you have some people saying it's racist
you have other people like this judge
that we're going to play from El Paso
saying there's no border crisis listen
there's no invasion of migrants in our
community nor are there hordes of
undocumented immigrants committing
crimes against citizens or causing havoc
in our community
Congressman Moran your reaction to that
state
yeah I was shocked by the judge's
statement I was a County judge in Texas
I've been down to the El Paso sector and
I can tell you what he said is simply
not true and in fact when I uh asked him
some questions he said hey 95 of the
money that we're using there locally is
from FEMA well FEMA is an emergency
management agency so clearly there's an
emergency management situation down
there in the Border there's a border
crisis I've seen it firsthand I know
from Texas judge standpoint we have to
secure our borders for various reasons
and you know Congressman there is um
obviously there's a bunch of different
crisis at the border right now but the
drugs infiltrating our border is a main
topic you know we had a top D.A official
saying that two different cartels are
the biggest threats to criminals the
criminal drug threats the U.S has ever
seen let's take a listen to this and
we'll talk about it
the Sinaloa and Jalisco cartels pose the
greatest criminal drug threat the United
States has ever faced
these ruthless violent criminal
organizations have Associates
facilitators and brokers in all 50
states the cartels are destroying
families and communities with callous
indifference and greed you know I think
one of the main issues is the what
they're calling the fentanyl crisis
right now do you think this is one of
the top if not the top crisis at the
border right now that we need to get a
hold on absolutely Ashley the sheriff is
right on yesterday when he talked about
both the drug trafficking and the human
trafficking but from a fentanyl
standpoint we have so much fentanyl in
this country right now it could kill all
Americans many times over we heard the
heart-wrenching story yesterday of a
father who talked about his 15 year old
son who died in Hays County last year
from a fentanyl overdose and it was just
tragic to hear his story so many
unfortunately lost lives due to this uh
due to these drugs and due to our
inability to stop the cartels bring
those drugs over our borders 73 000 in
fact from August 2020 to August 2021 so
how will Republicans put a stop to this
while Republicans are going to have to
cramp down immediately using our
Appropriations arm we'd also like to see
past chip Roy's Bill house resolution 29
that says basically look you either have
to detain folks or return them to the
country of origin we can no longer Catch
and Release and we can no longer have
our poorest borders it really comes down
to the administration the byte
Administration whether or not they want
to enforce the rule of law and their
policies that they're allowing at this
point that are making our borders so
poorest you know is title 42 and it's
going to be in place until I think June
sometime in June is it even working down
there because you see all of these
numbers these huge numbers of Fentanyl
and the cartels coming through what's
the point of it even right now if it's
not stopping while it's stopping the the
drugs and the cartels from coming over
the Border what's going to happen when
it's not in place
well you know we we've got to just to
step back and say to to ourselves this
is not a complicated issue we know
neighbor to neighbor when I when I was
growing up I knew my neighbor's yard
belonged to him and my and our yard
belonged to us and I couldn't trespass
without his permission private property
rights and the rule of law means
something that is not a a hard concept
to get to gain and countries around the
world enforce border security why can't
we do it here at home Congressman
Nathaniel Moran thank you so much for
your time this morning great Insight we
appreciate it thank you sir